.
Wenn Dunkelheit
und Ruhe einkehren ...
... und dem ganzen Land eine
geheimnisvolle Schönheit verleihen,
wenn die einen bereits schlafen, er-
zählen die anderen ihre Geschichten.
Geschichten, einzigartig
und verborgen, kommen zum Vorschein.
Auf unserer Reise von der Dämmerung
bis zum Morgengrauen
durch eine sommerliche Nacht
in der Schweiz.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Im Tessin, auf dem Monte Generoso,
thront das neue Panorama-Restaurant
Fiore di pietra von Mario Botta
und gibt den Blick frei
bis nach Mailand.
Das Casino von Mendrisio
erlebt einen Aufschwung,
seit das im italienischen Campione
pleitegegangen ist.
* Sanfte, rieselnde Klänge *
Nicht viel los ist hingegen
im Centro Ovale in Chiasso.
Das Shoppingcenter gilt als
erste Dead Mall in der Schweiz.
Erst 2011 eröffnet,
steht es seit fünf Jahren leer.
Der Grenzübergang Chiasso-Brogeda:
Nirgendwo sonst werden täglich
mehr Personen und Waren abgefertigt.
Und nirgendwo sonst
versuchen Migranten so oft,
über die Grüne Grenze zu gelangen.
Kaum ist es dunkel,
startet der Sondereinsatz
der eidg. Zollverwaltung.
Im Visier der Grenzwächter:
grenzüberschreitende Kriminalität
jeder Art.
Feldweibel Lorenzo Quattropani
leitet die Operation.
Seine Leute kommen
aus allen drei Sprachregionen.
(Italienisch)
Der Helikopter
gehört zur Schweizer Luftwaffe.
Sie unterstützt die Grenzwächter
seit vielen Jahren.
V.a. im Sommer kommt es vermehrt zu
illegalen Aktivitäten in Grenznähe.
* Rattern des Helikopters *
Am Boden unterstützt
Leutnant Michele Canubio
von der eidg. Zollverwaltung
die Operation.
Plötzlich entdeckt Quattropani
auf der Kamera rechts im Bild
einen Laser.
(Mann) Ah, warte, warte.
Eindeutig,
es ist der auf dem Balkon.
Die Operation
nimmt eine unerwartete Wende.
Die illegalen Grenzübertritte
müssen warten.
* Piepen *
Das Team am Boden wird vom Helikopter
an den mutmasslichen Ausgangspunkt
der Laserattacke gelotst.
Laserattacken werden in der Schweiz
äusserst streng geahndet.
Zur Sicherheit fordert Leutnant
Michele Canubio Verstärkung an.
Provo a veder se mi risponde
sull' elicottero.
Von den mutmasslichen Angreifern
keine Spur.
Für Laserattacken
drohen saftige Bussen
und Haftstrafen bis zu einem Jahr.
Der Damm von Melide.
* Sanfte, tapsige Klänge *
Der Blick vom San Salvatore
auf Lugano.
Ein Stück mediterranes Flair
in der Sonnenstube der Schweiz.
In den Sommermonaten herrscht hier
normalerweise Hochbetrieb.
In Zeiten von Corona wirkt
die Promenade ungewöhnlich leer.
Banken prägen das Stadtbild.
U.a. wegen ausgezeichneten Be-
ziehungen zum italienischen Geldadel
ist Lugano
der drittgrösste Finanzplatz im Land.
Richtung Norden,
über den Monte Ceneri
und den Monte Tamaro
zum Lago Maggiore.
Mittendrin die Isole di Brissago.
wo Baronessa
Antoinette de Saint Léger
vor rund 130 Jahren ihren
berühmten botanischen Garten anlegte.
* Sanfte, geheimnisvolle Klänge *
Zwischen Ascona und Locarno
das Maggia-Delta -
mit dem Zeltplatz Camping Delta.
Daniela Ambrosoli
hat den Platz in dritter Generation
von ihrem Vater übernommen.
Buona sera signora Ambrosini.
Grazie mille. Buona serata.
Arrivederci.
Buon lavoro.
- Grazie.
Ales Zalesny arbeitet hier bereits
die sechste Saison als Nachtwächter.
Der zweifache Vater
ist anders als seine Vorgänger.
Er liebt die einsamen Runden
zur nächtlichen Stunde.
Dieses Jahr ist es besonders ruhig.
250 Stellplätze für Zelte,
Wohnwagen und Wohnmobile
und 35 Saisonplätze
sind Ales' Revier.
Nach 22 Uhr gilt hier Nachtruhe.
Guten Abend.
- (Mann) Guten Abend.
Italiano? Deutsch?
- Deutsch.
Sind Sie unsere Gäste?
- Ja.
Okay, perfekt. Kein Problem.
Danke.
- Bitte.
Schönen Abend.
- Schönen Abend.
In diesem Jahr
ist sowieso vieles anders.
Statt Deutscher und Holländer
sind v.a. Schweizer hier.
* Leise Stimmen im Hintergrund *
Es ist nicht wirklich viel los.
Es ist sehr ruhig.
Um 22 Uhr ist Nachtruhe.
Aber sonst ... In Locarno ist wohl
schon ein bisschen was los.
Mittlerweile ist es nach Mitternacht.
Überall absolute Ruhe.
Fast.
Signori? Hallo? Mi scusi.
Parlate italiano? Deutsch?
- (Mehrere) Deutsch.
Okay, es ist fast 0.30 Uhr.
Unsere Regel ist: ab 22 Uhr ganz
ruhig, keine Musik, nichts. Okay?
Okay.
- Okay.
Dann wünsche ich gute Nacht.
- (Mehrere) Danke, gleichfalls.
Buona notte.
- Buona notte.
Bellinzona mit seinen
drei mittelalterlichen Burgen
liegt in der
strategisch wichtigen Talenge
vor den zwei Tälern
zur Alpenüberquerung -
der Leventina und dem Misox.
Die Befestigungen Castelgrande,
Castello die Montebello
und Castello die Sasso Corbaro
wurden zur Kontrolle der Alpenpässe
Nufenen, Gotthard, Lukmanier
und San Bernardino errichtet.
Sie waren lange Zankapfel
zwischen Italienern, Franzosen
und Eidgenossen.
* Majestätische Klänge *
* Schnelle, glockige Klänge *
Gegen Norden, Richtung Gotthard,
die Staumauer des Ritomsees.
Der A2 entlang
zum Südportal des Gotthardtunnels.
Hier wird in wenigen Stunden
ein spektakulärer Schwertransport
aus dem Kanton Nidwalden erwartet.
Zurzeit ist er auf der A2
im Kanton Uri unterwegs.
Noch einige Kilometer vom Nordportal
entfernt.
Verantwortlich:
die Kantonspolizei Uri.
Bär Michael, Kantonspolizei Uri.
Hallo?
Hallo,
Polizei Kanton Tessin.
Hallo, salut.
Hallo. Sprechen Sie
ein bisschen französisch?
Nein, leider nicht.
- Nein.
Wir erwarten Sie in Airolo.
- Jawohl.
Ist der Tunnel schon gesperrt?
Ja, wir sind schon hier.
Und ist schon gesperrt?
Der Tunnel?
- Entschuldigung?
Der Gottardtunnel
ist schon gesperrt?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es ist aperto o no.
Schon noch ...
- Ich weiss nicht.
Aber ich rufe ...
- Aber wir sind hier und warten.
Ja, sehr gut.
- Okay, danke.
Okay, bis später.
- Bis später. Danke.
Ciao.
Eine typische Konversation
über die Sprachgrenzen hinweg.
Wird schon gut gehen.
Mehr Sorgen macht Michael Bär
das Timing.
Es ist unmöglich, dass wir
um 2 Uhr in Airolo sein können.
Das ist eine Illusion.
Das wird 2.30 Uhr, 3 Uhr.
Bis zu 4.30 m breit, bis 53 m lang
und über 80 t schwer
ist die geladene Fracht.
Bestandteile der neuen
Windkraftanlage auf dem Gotthardpass.
Nervös werde ich erst,
wenn jemand nicht mehr fährt
oder etwas Spezielles passiert.
Wir hatten schon solche Konvois
in die Gegenrichtung,
bei denen plötzlich jemand funkte:
"Ich muss anhalten,
ich habe Ölverlust."
Oder irgendetwas -
eine kaputte Leitung.
Wenn so ein Riesenkonvoi
auf offener Strecke anhalten muss,
dann ...
ist das sicher nicht so angenehm.
Etwas später als geplant,
kurz vor 2.30 Uhr,
erreichen die Lkws
das Nadelöhr des Transports:
das Nordportal des Gotthardtunnels.
Konvoi kann weiterfahren,
trotz Rotlicht.
Ich halte den Verkehr an.
Guten Abend,
Bär von der Kantonspolizei.
Ich wäre froh,
wenn Sie hier warten würden.
Der Tunnel
ist für ca. 20 Min. gesperrt.
Okay?
- Wegen Ausnahmetransporten.
Sie dürfen erst weiterfahren,
wenn es auf Grün wechselt.
Kein Problem.
- Also. Perfekt, vielen Dank.
Können wir hier warten? - Ja.
Über den Pass ist auch schlecht ...
Wieso wird das Grün?
- Auto abstellen?
Ja, Sie können abstellen.
Pannenblinker, da es ein Fahrzeug
ist, aber das ist nicht gut.
Uri EZ von Bär, antworten.
Alle Fahrzeuge müssen warten.
Verstanden.
Warum steht es auf Grün?
In Göschenen. Antworten.
(Funk) Verstanden,
das ist richtig, antworten.
Du musst es auf Rot lassen,
bis wir aus Airolo Bescheid geben.
Jetzt kann der Konvoi
seine Fahrt sicher fortsetzen.
(Männerstimme) Signore e Signori,
benvenuti nella galleria
autostradale del San Gottardo.
Mantenetevi sintonizzati
su questa frequenza,
in modo da ricevere
gli importanti informazioni.
Das Gotthardmassiv.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Rohne, Reuss, Rhein und Ticino
entspringen hier
und fliessen
in alle Himmelsrichtungen,
bis ins Mittelmeer
und in die Nordsee.
In einer klaren Nacht gut sichtbar:
das Schreckhorn im Berner Oberland,
der nördlichste 4'000er Europas.
Die Grimselstaumauer
wird gerade saniert.
19 Min. später.
Ohne Zwischenfall
erreicht der Schwertransportkonvoi
nach 16,9 km das Südportal.
Massarbeit.
Nur wenige Zentimeter bleiben zwi-
schen der Tunneldecke und der Ladung,
den Motorgehäusen der Windkrafträder.
Grazie mille. Buon lavoro. Ciao.
Der anschliessende Anstieg
auf der Gotthard-Passstrasse
ist für alle
eine echte Herausforderung.
Auch für routinierte Chauffeure.
Wir hatten schon diverse Fahrten
hier hoch.
Da kennt man die Chauffeure,
die nun unterwegs sind.
Einige kenne ich schon Jahre.
Wir hatten
schon einige spektakuläre Transporte
oder durften gemeinsam
interessante Sachen durchführen.
So ist dieser Kontakt gewachsen.
Die Windräder auf dem Gotthardpass
werden die grössten in den Alpen sein
und 15 % der landesweiten Windenergie
produzieren.
Insgesamt sechs Haarnadelkurven
müssen noch überwunden werden.
Diese Ausnahmetransporte hier
sind eigentlich die Königsklasse
im Transportgewerbe.
Am Ostufer des Urnersees
liegen der Urner Berg Rophaien
und die schroffe Steilwand Axen.
Jahrhunderte lang zwang sie Reisende
auf mühsame Saumpfade
oder aufs Schiff,
um vom Süden nach Norden
und umgekehrt zu gelangen.
"Sei gegrüsst, mein Bruder!"
"Heut komm ich zu dir ohne Ruder",
hiess es nach zweieinhalb Jahren
Bauzeit am 3. Juli 1865
zur Eröffnung der Axenstrasse.
* Pompöse Klänge *
Auch noch heute, 150 Jahre später,
gilt das Bauwerk
als technische Meisterleistung.
Die Schweiz aus der Luft
ist gesprenkelt
mit hell erleuchteten,
von Weitem sichtbaren grünen Flächen.
Auf über 10'000 Fussballplätzen
wird spätabends mit Flutlicht
trainiert und gespielt.
* Erhabene Klänge *
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Der Bahnhof von Luzern,
entworfen von Santiago Calatrava.
Die Kappellbrücke.
Nach dem Brand 1993 wurde die
älteste überdachte Holzbrücke Europas
originalgetreu wieder aufgebaut.
Luzern zählt keine 100'000 Einwohner,
aber die Stadt
lockt mit Kulturveranstaltungen
und v.a. mit seiner Aussicht
auf die Alpen
jährlich Millionen von Touristen an.
An den Wochenenden
verkehren hier die Nachtbuslinien
der Luzerner Verkehrsbetriebe,
die sog. Nachtsterne.
Hallo zusammen.
Schutzmaske habt ihr dabei?
Ja, haben wir dabei.
- Perfekt, dann sind es 30 Fr.
Das Billett könnt ihr selber nehmen.
Genau.
Wir sind sehr gut geschützt
dank Vorkehrungen wie Schutzscheiben
oder dass wir Handschuhe tragen
können und selber Maske tragen.
Von daher habe ich gar kein Problem.
Zu Beginn der Pandemie
mit dem Coronavirus
wurden die Nachtsterne ausgesetzt.
Mittlerweile chauffiert Reto Wirth
seine Gäste wieder durch die Nacht.
Grüezi wohl.
Bis wohin?
Sie können es dort rausnehmen.
Vielen Dank.
Und drei sind zehn.
Generell sehe ich den Nachstern
als etwas Positives,
da ich auch wieder
sehr viel Freiheit habe
und selbstständig unterwegs bin.
Es sind auch ganz andere Fahrgäste
als tagsüber.
Es ist speziell.
Über 2'500 Fahrgäste nutzen an einem
normalen Party-Weekend den Nachtbus
in Luzern und Umgebung.
Reto Wirth arbeitet gerne nachts.
Er ist stolz,
die Nachtschwärmer zu chauffieren.
Gute Nacht, danke.
Gerade wenn es um die Frauen geht -
dass wir sie
sicher nach Hause bringen können.
Es macht mich sehr happy.
Denn ich finde es interessant,
mit unterschiedlichen Fahrgästen
unterwegs zu sein.
Ich finde diese Aufgabe
sehr spannend.
Endgültig parkieren wird Reto Wirth
seinen Bus heute Nacht um 4.42 Uhr.
Weit über dem Vierwaldstättersee
strahlt wie eine riesige Lichtleiter
der Hammetschwand Lift.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Mit den Füssen
steht er im Kanton Luzern.
Das Aussichtsplateau des Bürgenstocks
jedoch
gehört bereits zum Kanton Nidwalden.
* Feierliche Klänge *
Auf der Klewenalp
brennt eines der wenigen Höhenfeuer.
Es ist der 1. August.
Normalerweise werden in dieser Nacht
auf vielen Hügeln Feuer angezündet.
Im Corona-Sommer
ist alles ein bisschen anders.
Auch das Feuerwerk am Thunersee
ist eine absolute Ausnahme.
* Entspannte Klavierklänge *
Thun - Tor zum Berner Oberland
und Militärstadt.
Seit der Eröffnung der Militärschule
1819 und bis heute noch
ist Thun
der grösste Waffenplatz der Schweiz.
Das Schloss Schadau
ist heute ein Boutique-Hotel.
Vor bald 180 Jahren wurde es
für Bankier Abraham Denis Alfred
de Rougemont erbaut.
* Kuhglocken vermischen sich
mit den Klavierklängen. *
Absolute Dunkelheit
im Dreieck Thun-Bern-Fribourg -
der Naturpark Gantrisch.
(Frau) Es ist ein sehr heimeliges
Gefühl, hier unterwegs zu sein.
Man hat einen Wahnsinnssternenhimmel
für sich alleine.
Man ist alleine, aber nicht einsam.
Das ist
ein schönes ... schönes Gefühl,
nachts unterwegs zu sein.
Nicole Dahinden untersucht hier
die Lichtverschmutzung.
Dabei helfen ihr
senkrecht in den Nachthimmel
fotografierte Fischaugenaufnahmen.
Gute Werte sind die dunkeln.
Es sind teilweise
beinahe schwarze Punkte darunter.
Wenn auf diesem Bild
die Milchstrasse nicht wäre,
würde man
einen sehr dunklen Himmel sehen.
Hier ist ein Wert von 21,58.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Perfekt wären 21,8 Magnituden.
In Städten liegen die Werte
wegen der Lichtverschmutzung
nur zwischen 16 und 19.
Man sieht hier die Gantrischkette.
Das ist im Süden.
Im Norden ist Bern,
aber das ist stark abgeschirmt
von diesem Hügelzug.
Man sieht hier auch die Bäume.
Man sieht auch hier die Lichtver-
schmutzung von Thun her, im Osten.
Und auch hier sieht man einen
kleinen rot-gelben Ausschlag,
der von Westen her kommt.
Das ist bereits von der Westschweiz,
vom Kanton Fribourg.
Wir möchten, dass sich die Nacht
wieder viel stärker ausbreitet,
dass sich die Dunkelheit
wieder stärker ausbreitet
und das Licht zurückdrängt.
Der Gurnigel, ein Hügelzug,
gilt im Naturpark Gantrisch
weltweit als einer der zehn
besten Orte, um Sterne zu beobachten.
Wow, so habe ich den noch selten
gesehen. Das ist wirklich genial.
Auch Hobbyastronom Stefan Meister
kommt seit Jahren hierher.
Heute bietet der Saturn
mit seinen Ringen
ein ganz besonderes Spektakel.
Jetzt sieht man
die beiden Ringe sehr schön,
die getrennt sind.
Man sieht auserdem ...
... die Struktur der Wolken
auf dem Saturn.
Das leichte Flimmern
ist die Luft, durch die wir schauen.
So ruhig und so absolut scharf -
unglaublich.
Ich beobachte seit etwa 40 Jahren.
Das ist
bisher zwei-, dreimal passiert,
dass es so perfekt war.
Wahnsinn. Genial.
Mit seinem selbstgebauten Teleskop
wirkt auch der hellste Stern
am Himmel zum Greifen nah.
Die Venus, 40 Mio. km entfernt.
Innerhalb eines halben Jahres
entstand das bei mir
im Keller und in der Küche.
Mit Drehbank und Säge und Oberfräse.
Es besteht aus Holz und Metall,
mit einer
etwas speziellen Montierung.
Aber in dieser Montierung
gibt es keine Elektronik.
Das ist alles manuell. Ich kann
das Fernrohr von Hand bewegen.
Es ist zwar 30 kg schwer,
aber ich kann
es mit dem kleinen Finger bewegen,
als würde es auf Butter laufen.
Die grossen Waldflächen um die ehe-
malige Panzerplattform Stierenhütte
erlauben einen nahezu
ungetrübten Blick in die Nacht.
Nicole Dahinden
setzt sich seit Jahren
für die Bewahrung
des dunklen Nachhimmels ein.
Man muss darauf achten,
wo und wie man beleuchtet,
und zu welchem Zweck.
Man soll nicht einfach Licht machen,
wo man gerade Lust hat,
sondern
ein bisschen nachhaltig überlegen:
Wofür brauche ich dieses Licht?
Brauche ich es wirklich
und in dieser Intensität?
Für welchen Zweck
brauche ich überhaupt Licht?
Bei Dunkelheit und klarer Sicht
kann der Mensch etwa 6'500 Sterne
mit blossem Auge erkennen.
Zu diesem Sternenhimmel,
den jeder Mensch auf der Welt
sehen können müsste,
sind so viele Gedanken entstanden,
so viele ... Gedichte,
und so viel Kunstvolles,
so viele Bilder
sind auch in der Nacht entstanden.
Das finde ich etwas Schönes: alleine
unter dem Sternenhimmel zu sein.
Es ist ein Fenster zum All, zu
dieser Leere oder zum vollen All.
Das ist total spannend.
* Beschauliche, glockige Klänge *
Die A6.
Neben ihr die Aare
auf ihrem Weg nach Bern.
Auf der Raststätte Münsingen
ist nicht viel los in dieser Nacht.
Auch östlich davon, im Emmental,
ist es dunkel.
Vereinzelt nur
brennt auf den Höfen Licht.
Einer davon ist Ranbühl.
* Leise, beschwingte Klänge *
Da ist mehr Butter drin
als in einem normalen Zopf.
Theres Steiner und ihre Tochter Anita
backen fünf verschiedene Sorten Brot.
Und aufs Wochenende hin
Sonntagszöpfe, ihre Spezialität.
Bereits seit dem frühen Abend
stehen sie in der Backstube.
Ich kann zu jeder Tages-
und Nachtzeit aufstehen,
das spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Die jüngste Tochter
ist gelernte Bäckerin-Konditorin.
Ich habe sie am Morgen
immer aus dem Haus gehen hören.
Um 2, 3, 4 Uhr.
Auch jetzt
brauche ich keinen Wecker.
Ich wache ...
Ab 4 Uhr bin ich eigentlich wach -
oder ab 4.30, 5 Uhr.
Für mich ist das kein Opfer,
ausser dass ich
etwas weniger Schlaf bekomme.
Aber ich helfe gerne ab und zu aus.
Es ist nicht jedes Mal,
dass ich helfen muss - oder darf.
Hauptsächlich kümmert sich Anita
um den heimischen Hof.
In der Backstube ihrer Mutter
arbeitet sie in Teilzeit.
Theres hat schon immer gern gebacken.
Vor 16 Jahren hat ihr Mann für sie
eine eigene Backstube eingerichtet.
* Hohler Klang *
Klingt gut.
- Ja.
Gut, oder?
So teste ich,
ob der Zopf fertig gebacken ist.
Je hohler er klingt,
desto besser durch ist er.
Bei Mutter habe ich gelernt,
dass man so überprüft,
ob er lange genug im Ofen war.
* Hohler Klang *
Die Brote und Sonntagszöpfe
sind für den Bauernmarkt
in der Berner Münstergasse bestimmt.
Meist sind sie schnell ausverkauft.
Das ist eine Herausforderung.
Ich weiss es nie zum Voraus.
Wetterbericht hören - wird es schön?
Für Sonntag sind Gewitter
in den Bergen gemeldet,
da gehen wohl nicht alle wandern.
Entsprechend backe ich -
mal mehr, mal weniger.
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Wir hatten auch schon
um 10 Uhr keine Zöpfe mehr.
Aber sonst geht es auf,
so bis 11.30 Uhr.
Dann hat man noch ein paar Brote
und etwas Süsses.
Das kann man dann bis 12.15,
12.30 Uhr auch noch verkaufen.
Das ist ... gut.
Mehl, Salz und Zucker mischen,
Hefe zerbröckeln, daruntermischen.
Butter mit der Milch beigeben,
mischen
und zu einem weichen, glatten Teig
kneten.
Am Ende ist er 5 kg schwer,
der grösste Zopf der Steiners.
Das Rezept verrate ich nicht.
Das ist ein uraltes Rezept
der Mutter meiner Mutter.
Ich habe gesagt,
das verrate ich nicht.
So sind diese Rezepte
halt Geheimnisse.
Wie sie backen kann ich nicht,
das kriege ich nicht hin.
Nach all den Jahren nicht.
Manchmal rufe ich an:
"Wie geht das?"
Sie sagt mir,
wie viel sie wovon nimmt
und: "Dann musst du halt schauen."
Also.
Es reicht gerade noch
für eine kleine Pause,
bevor sie los muss nach Bern.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Nur gerade 143'000 Einwohner
zählt die Bundeshauptstadt.
Das Münster wurde
bis auf den oberen Teil des Turms
komplett aus Berner Sandstein erbaut.
Und um das ganze Land
zu repräsentieren,
wurden im Bundeshaus
nahezu alle in der Schweiz vor-
kommenden Gesteinssorten verwendet.
Die Berner Altstadt gehört mit
ihren Gassen und den langen Lauben
seit 1983 zum UNESCO-Weltkulturerbe.
Der Circus Knie
hat seine Tournee wegen Corona
sehr spät
und ausnahmsweise in Bern begonnen.
Auf die Aufführungen
in der Westschweiz und im Tessin
wird ganz verzichtet.
Die A1 verbindet
die West- mit der Ostschweiz.
Mit 410 km
die längste Autobahn des Landes.
Verkehrstechnisch günstig gelegen:
das Shoppyland,
die Gegend um das Autobahnkreuz
Schönbühl.
* Dunkle, pulsierende Klänge *
Am Südfuss des Jura: Solothurn.
Barockstadt und dank
der Film- und Literaturtage
wichtiges Kulturzentrum.
33 kg wiegt die riesige
feuervergoldete Kupferkugel,
die den Turm der St. Ursen-Kathedrale
krönt.
* Fröhliche Rufe und Kreischen
im Hintergrund *
Am Ufer der Aare, auf dem Gelände
einer ehemaligen Zellulosefabrik,
befindet sich das Attisholz Areal.
Heute wird es
als Kulturtreffpunkt genutzt.
Bis 2040 soll hier
ein Generationenprojekt zum Wohnen,
Arbeiten und Leben für
mehrere Tausend Menschen entstehen.
Der Weissenstein,
der Hausberg der Stadt
und Heimat für die Jäger der Nacht.
Im Nidleloch,
einem weitverzweigten Höhlensystem,
das bis zu 407 m in die Tiefe führt,
finden Fledermäuse
einen perfekten Rückzugsort.
Mit der sog. Harfenfalle fängt
Biologe Elias Bader die Säugetiere.
Eine Harfenfalle funktioniert
nach einem ganz einfachen Prinzip.
Sie besteht aus zwei
mit Nylonfäden bespannten Rahmen.
Wenn eine Fledermaus zur Höhle
hinein- oder hinausfliegt,
muss sie zwischen den Fäden
durchfliegen.
Das tut sie,
indem sie sich so aufstellt
oder die Flügel zusammenfaltet.
Sie fliegt hindurch und muss
danach die Flügel wieder ausbreiten.
Sie hat vor dem zweiten Rahmen
nicht genügend Zeit, zu reagieren,
bleibt dort hängen
und fällt in die Auffangtasche.
Fledermäuse machen in der Schweiz
rund einen Drittel
aller Säugetierarten aus.
Bechsteinfledermaus.
* Klickern *
Männchen.
Adult.
Elias Bader und Katja Rauchenstein
erforschen dieses einzige Säugetier,
das fliegen kann.
Unterarmlänge: 44,3.
Wir kamen zum Schluss:
Die sog. Ökosystemdienstleistungen,
die die Fledermäuse in der Schweiz
für die Menschen erbringen,
würden einem Geldbetrag zwischen
einem dreistelligen Millionen-
und einem tiefen Milliardenbetrag
pro Jahr entsprechen.
Eine knappe Milliarde.
Das haben die Forscher berechnet.
So gross
wäre der Verlust der Landwirte,
würden die Fledermäuse
nicht Nacht für Nacht Insekten jagen.
* Knistern *
Zwergfledermaus.
- Sind auch dabei.
Biologin Katja Rauchenstein
hat ihre Masterarbeit
über Fledermäuse geschrieben.
Dieses Gerät bringt die Rufe
in den für uns hörbaren Bereich.
So können wir sie hören.
Wir gehören gerade
eine Zwergfledermaus,
die um uns herumschwirrt.
Viele Arten kann man
anhand der Rufe unterscheiden.
Insgesamt
27 verschiedene Fledermausarten
wurden im Jura bereits gesichtet.
Bis zu 8 Std.
verbringen Katja und Elias
nachts gemeinsam in der Karsthöhle.
Es ist sicher wichtig,
dass man sich versteht.
Man ist die ganze Nacht
gemeinsam draussen.
Es ist auch sehr wichtig,
die Abläufe zu kennen,
zu wissen, was man
in welcher Reihenfolge macht.
Dass die Handgriffe sitzen,
alles bereit liegt,
damit man die Fledermäuse
so kurz wie möglich festhält
und so schnell wie möglich
wieder fliegen lässt.
Einerseits ist es alleine
ziemlich anstrengend,
besonders, wenn es viele Fledermäuse
sind. Da rotiert man alleine.
Andererseits
ist es auch etwas langweilig,
wenn man 6 Std.
alleine im dunkeln Wald sitzt.
Besonders wenn mal nichts läuft.
Wenn man 6 Std. auf seinem Stühlchen
wartet, dass etwas passiert,
ist es angenehmer,
Gesellschaft zu haben.
* Hohes Klickern *
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wo die Nord-Süd- und die
Ost-West-Achsen aufeinandertreffen:
das Autobahnkreuz Härkingen.
Praktisch alle Pakete
für das Mittelland landen hier:
im grössten Postpaketzentrum.
Jede Nacht werden 400'000 Pakete an
die zuständigen Postämter verteilt.
Fast zwei Drittel davon
werden über die Schiene in
alle Himmelsrichtungen transportiert.
Gegen Norden, zur Grenze hin:
der Grossraum Basel.
Einige Agglomerationsgemeinden gehö-
ren zu Frankreich und Deutschland.
Viele der über 800'000 Einwohner
arbeiten darum als Grenzgänger
in der Metropole.
Basel als weltweit führendes Zentrum
der Chemie- und Pharmaindustrie
demonstriert dies
mit Roche Tower 1 und 2 eindrücklich.
Die beiden Türme
der Architekten Herzog & de Meuron
überragen die Altstadt
um das Zehnfache.
Pläne für einen dritten,
noch höheren Turm liegen vor.
Von der Mittleren Rheinbrücke abwärts
gilt der Rhein
als internationales Gewässer
und sichert der Schweiz über
Rotterdam den Zugang zur Nordsee.
* Applaus, jazzige Klänge *
Einer der wenigen Events,
die dieses Jahr stattfinden.
Anfangs war das Musikfestival
IMFLUSS sehr umstritten.
Einige Anwohner
zogen sogar bis vor Bundesgericht,
um es zu verbieten.
* Jubel *
Heute ist es aus dem Basler Sommer
nicht mehr wegzudenken.
Grössere Schwierigkeiten
hat das dem Messezentrum Basel.
Die berühmte Uhrenmesse Baselworld
und die Kunstmesse Art Basel
wurde wegen der Pandemie abgesagt.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Die Trämli bedienen die
gesamte trinationale Agglomeration
mit Endstationen
in Frankreich und Deutschland.
Centralbahnhof, Elsässerbahnhof
und Badischer Bahnhof -
auch Bahnhöfe gibt es drei.
Am Dreiländereck
befinden sich die Rheinhäfen.
Umschlagplatz
für Waren aus aller Welt.
Fabio, die Nummer ist: UHCU 377-9.
Kannst du dann als Nächstes bringen.
Die Grenzgänger
Fabio Piraino und Tim Hebestreit
sind kurz vor Ende
ihrer Nachtschicht.
Fabio wohnt in Frankreich,
Tim in Deutschland.
Unser schöner Künz-Kran,
der grösste in der Schweiz, 700 t,
hat richtig Kraft
und in der Nacht
ist er am schönsten.
Hier werden jährlich
6-7 Mio. t Güter umgeschlagen.
Fabio geniesst es,
alleine so weit oben.
Die Aussicht ist schön.
Man kann hier Basel sehen.
Ab und zu kommen ein paar Schiffe.
Für das Feuerwerk
hat man hier die beste Aussicht.
Man sieht wirklich alles.
Die Anbindung des Rheins
an das Strassennetz
und die Schienen der SBB Cargo
ist die Drehscheibe
zwischen den Seehäfen
Rotterdam und Genua.
Im Schiff, beim Lkw und beim Zug -
abladen, laden - muss man
wirklich sehr genau arbeiten.
Wir reden hier von Millimeterarbeit.
Wenn man das Gefühl dafür nicht hat,
ist man für diesen Beruf
nicht geschaffen.
Jeder vierte Container
des Landes
wird über diese Terminals
abgewickelt.
Fabio macht das seit 15 Jahren.
Höhenkoller kennt er nicht.
Wir haben schon viele gehabt, die
nach 5 Min. wieder runter mussten.
Es ist echt nicht für jedermann,
hier oben zu sitzen.
Man schaut die ganze Zeit runter,
die Kabine wackelt.
Ich bin schwindelfrei,
mir dreht auch der Kopf nicht.
Ich gehe gerne auf Karussells
und so.
Ich hatte damit noch nie Probleme.
Fabio arbeitet im Schichtbetrieb.
Genauso wie Tim.
Die Nacht ist einfach am tollsten.
Da komme ich voll aus mir raus,
kann ein bisschen Chef spielen.
Ja, Nachtschicht ist ...
... schon eine geile Arbeit.
Aber das Privatleben
leidet manchmal schon.
Wenn man Frau oder Kinder hat,
ist es schwierig.
Man geht nachts aus dem Haus,
die Kinder am Morgen zur Schule.
Man kommt am Morgen nach Hause,
sieht die Kinder nicht.
Die Frau geht zur Arbeit.
Die Frau oder Freundin muss viel
Verständnis haben für diesen Beruf.
Kurz vor 6 Uhr morgens
haben es die beiden geschafft.
Zeit, den Kran zu parkieren.
Noch ein Stück.
Halt.
Ich mach den Verschluss zu.
Du kannst Feierabend machen. Super
Tag, wir haben alles geschafft.
Heute war ein guter Tag.
Heute war bei uns ein Grosskampftag.
Wir haben alles gut durchdacht
und vorbereitet,
und können heute sagen:
"Wir haben's gerockt."
Die Nacht neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Ein neuer Tag in
der sommerlichen Schweiz bricht an.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020